we all know that we are in a global
world companies have operations all over
the planet and a big question we have to
face is how do we keep these global
corporations accountable for providing
good jobs and decent work in far-flung
places and let's do it through a company
we all know and love nike nike was a
pioneer in this area in the 1960s nike
was one of the first companies that said
we will design our work here we will
market and sell our products around the
world particularly in the United States
but we can find cheaper places to
manufacture them first they started in
Japan and then Korea and then Indonesia
and Vietnam and China and Bangladesh as
they did so a number of problems became
known the Nike products were marketed
well with Michael Jordan and so on but
Labor Standards became a problem they
were famously found having child labor
to having unsafe working conditions to
having long hours of unpaid overtime in
their factories abroad and what was
Nikes response well wait a minute these
aren't our problems these are our
contractors these are not our employees
we don't treat our employees that way
somebody else's problem that lasted for
a while but it by the middle of the
1990s nike watched its stock price begin
to fall it saw the publicity ginn to
grow and grow and finally phil knight
the CEO of nike made this famous
statement he said Nikes products have
become synonymous with slave wages
forced overtime and arbitrary abuse and
we need to do something about it to
change that image or we're going to
suffer as a company so what did Nike do
well to its credit it took a whole set
of actions first it created a social
responsibility unit within its
organization and assign people the
responsibility to say fix this problem
that was a good start but not enough
second they created what are called
codes of conduct
they establish minimum wages and rules
against sexual harassment and rules for
maximum hours and overtime and freedom
of association and they started to apply
that code of conduct to all factories
that they contracted with throughout
their global supply chain they sent
auditors out there to measure compliance
with its code of conduct they took some
of their expert operations managers and
manufacturing experts sent them to some
of these plants to help consult to help
people both build safe working
conditions but also efficient ways of
manufacturing products to improve safety
improve quality improve productivity
they went on and worked with a variety
of non-governmental organizations or
NGOs in these countries who were
advocating for improved employment
conditions safety standards and in some
cases environmental standards in these
factories they shared this auto data
with academic researchers including a
team of researchers here at MIT where
they started to analyze the data and
learn what works and what didn't they
also created a website and to their
credit you can go on this website and
you can find all of their factories
listed you can find the audit scores and
you can find an analysis of what is
working and a very frank analysis of
what isn't working they met here at MIT
and later at Stanford with multiple
stakeholders NGOs academics competitors
suppliers in forming what they call a
just supply chain project and set of
practices the research findings from our
MIT project led by my colleague Richard
Locke reached a number of conclusions
first they found that NGO pressure was
really important to get this thing going
Nike and other companies like
hewlett-packard and other electronics
firms and other consumer companies that
followed in Nikes footsteps did it
because there was transparency and
pressure that was being brought to bear
to get them to do so the codes of
conduct were successful in the audits
were successful but only partially they
seem to bring the practices up to about
fifty to sixty percent of the overall
goals that were established in the
standards that were set so has lots of
room for improvement the standard that
was most frequently violated was around
working hours and overtime hours why is
that it's important for us to know
because we are part of the problem as we
are fickle consumers all of a sudden we
want the latest logo or the latest scarf
for the latest shirt and so the company
puts pressure on the supply chain to get
those products in a hurry and the
contractor they're out in Asia or
somewhere else says to employees I need
those I need them today and get them
done no matter what or we're going to
lose this contract and so they work long
hours and they're forced to work
overtime and all kinds of bad things
happen after that but the scores of
suppliers that God better had three key
ingredients first they got management
help from Nike and other companies
secondly they were in countries that had
stronger rules of law less corrupt
governments and they had stronger rules
governing human rights and commercial
practices and so the environment of the
country matters so this is all great
progress companies have learned how to
do this but what about us if we're part
of the problem we ought to be part of
the solution there are a number of
things that have been very positive
there's an organization on college
campuses around the country called
United students against sweatshops and
they have put pressure on their
universities universities like Cornell
and brown and Wisconsin and others to
make sure that they're only buying their
university logo apparel and athletic
wear from companies that have these
kinds of just supply chain practices in
place so we can do this but it takes a
lot of energy and a lot of collective
effort and it has to be done by all the
parties working together companies can't
do it alone NGOs can't do it alone local
governments can't do it alone but if
they all work together and build a
sustained
and effort to improve the conditions and
then produce the data that makes it all
transparent for us as consumers we can
make a difference in improving the
conditions of very low wage workers in
many developing countries so I'd like to
ask you two questions Apple our computer
friends and iPhone friends and iPod
friends are about two decades behind
Nike they have experienced terrible
problems with their contractors in China
and elsewhere you may have heard about
Foxconn with suicides of workers
frustrated with terrible working
conditions if you were to write to the
CEO of Apple what should a pelear from
Nikes experiences and then more broadly
what can you do to hold companies
accountable for their global operations
how can we take responsibility for
making sure that every shirt every tie
every sweatshirt that we buy is made in
a just supply chain and keep asking and
be willing to pay for products that are
made under fair working conditions we
can do that individually as consumers
and we can collectively set the norms
that is that essentially say to any
company if you want our business that
you've got to demonstrate that you are
providing safe and healthy working
conditions fair wages for people
wherever they make these products
you